uh please say that joining me now is the
education secretary and supporter of
this trust that's james cleve james
cleveland good morning to you thanks so
much for being with us why won't liz
trust richie soon boris johnson whoever
else sit down now to try and put anxious
families at ease about the prices
they're going to see come october well
the government the chancellor and the
business secretary have hauled in the
leaders of the energy companies to hold
them to account to do to discuss with
them what they are going to do with
these unexpected unplanned unprecedented
profits that they have been making
because of that sudden spike in energy
prices caused by russia's invasion of
ukraine the candidate's been putting
forward their plans liz has announced
that she will be
putting a temporary moratorium on the
green levees that push up
energy bills to an extent she's also
said she won't be going ahead with
national insurance rise that will put
forward
that will put back 240 pounds of
national insurance rise best part of 200
pounds into the pockets of people
and also what she said she is going to
do is bring forward an emergency budget
as soon as the house
comes back to address these issues
before the prices of energy uh go up
when the price cap is is is lifted um in
october you know this reported that many
families on the lowest incomes can have
a shortfall of some sixteen hundred
pounds now you talk about the chancellor
and the deems of hawaii and uh
quasi-quality business actually speaking
to the energy companies today is that an
acceptance then that the whimple tax
that the former chancellor put in was
inadequate
well we have already got a support
package in place a very
very very significant unprecedentedly
large support package in place we
recognize that prices are
are projected to go up
higher than the initial projections and
so that's why
liz has said that she will look at that
that's best done through an emergency
budget that's not something you can do
through recall parliament we have to do
that we have a new prime minister when
the house comes back in september we can
do that
before those prices go up uh in october
as we know they inevitably will yeah but
what i'm pushing one is this windfall
tax idea you are here i know you were
supporting this trust but you were also
government minister so i do want to get
an answer from the government because we
haven't heard from them very much in the
past few days so is this an acceptance
that the whimple tax that was put in
place with those carve outs to try and
encourage investment was wrong was was
misplaced and we need to go further look
what we're seeing is that the energy
cost the whole global energy costs are
still increasing faster now we need to
increasing higher so we need to respond
to that now the decisions that were made
at the time were the right decisions i
have no doubt about that but the
situation ukraine has uh dragged out the
energy cost implications have uh have
changed and of course as a responsible
government we we constantly need to
review the situation but of course the
other thing that we need to do which uh
doesn't get talked about so much is to
is to try and bring these prices these
wholesale energy prices back down again
that's why it's so important when we
deal in my old job and what liz is doing
as foreign secretary is to make sure
those energy generating countries those
oil and gas producing countries uh
increase production to to try and bring
those prices down and we've seen the
prices starting to come down
it won't filter through to people's
pockets as quickly as we would like and
that's why as i say liz has said she
will bring forward an emergency budget
as soon as we get back in september
ahead of those price rises in october
yeah and i think a deal has been signed
to bring in gas from the united states
as well in the past few days which
hopefully will help now actually move on
to your brief as well as education
secretary i know you knew in the gig um
but
schools are going to really struggle
this winter to be able to heat
the buildings and also feed the kids i
mean what's going to be done to make
sure that those schools can meet the
energy needs that they will have well
and this is why and i know you know
gordon brown who frankly should know
better has been telling everyone oh we
just recall parliament all these
problems go away it is a much more
complicated and therefore the government
answer needs to be a more comprehensive
answer than just come back for an
emergency debate in the summer because
you're right these energy price
pressures are hitting everyone both at
home
and businesses but of course as you're
right
as you say in my department this is
hitting schools universities
colleges
and we do need to look at what we can do
about that but it needs to be done it
needs to be done as an overall package
and it needs to be done with the
ultimate intention which is to bring
these costs down you can't just keep
chasing higher costs because we've got
to remember there's no such thing as
government money so whatever support
package we put in whether it be to
individuals or to organizations like
schools and colleges need to be paid for
and it's paid for out of taxation and
everyone loves the idea of more taxation
because they all think someone ever
because they're always not everywhere
they always think someone else is going
to pay you could borrow him so but let's
let's look i want to focus in on this
schooling of course i
apologize look the department for
education put out a survey early in the
year asking head teachers about the
costs that they would be incurring that
then was
the results of it were deferred in july
because of political uncertainties i
think it's probably when you were coming
into the job so when are teachers going
to know the amount of money that they're
going to expect because there was a
promise that there would be a little
extra funding for schools is that still
going to come are they going extra
funding well we uh we had a funding
announcement just before i stepped into
the
the job it was a it was a good funding
uh package but we absolutely recognize
that the costs have still continued to
ratchet up in large part because of this
invasion of ukraine and as i say
an emergency budget is the best place
one of those kind of set-piece fiscal
events is one of the best place to look
at the whole range of
income and expenditure within government
that's the right way to do that
we are absolutely looking at those costs
that schools and colleges and
universities uh are having to deal with
but as i say one of the the best ways of
doing this is to bring those costs down
and that's not that's that's not
happening this short term as you as you
readily admit and you and you could say
that you are going to make sure that
schools have adequate funding to make
sure that the buildings are warm enough
for the kids this just well of course
we've got a we've got to ensure that
schools can teach and the colleges can
teach and universities can teach we've
also got to make sure as i say that we
do we we whatever we do has to be done
in an economically sustainable way and i
know that it is it you know it is
disconcerting of course it is
for very worried
i totally get that i totally get that
and everyone's going to be feeling and
we are going to respond to that but as i
say the most sustainable way of doing
that is to push down those prices and
that's going to take international
effort as well as domestic politicians
should the uk be braced for blackouts
come january
well
we've got to understand that we we are
in a global
market we're in a global energy market
and the things which are affecting us
are affecting everyone around the world
we're in a better position than many in
terms of our domestic
energy production um and
you know there is every reason to
believe that we can get through this and
it's not going to be easy but we are a
resilient we've seen this through uh
through the covid situation we are
resourceful
resilient
agile uh country will continue to be so
yeah i mean you saw how badly going
covered so it could be this bad and we
could have blackouts come this winter no
i'm not saying that at all that's that's
what you're saying that's not what i was
saying the point i'm making is that um
we recognize the challenges that are
coming we will ensure that we plan
appropriately for what our global
circumstances including as you said
ensuring that there is a uh an overall
increase in production where we can
influence our international partners to
do so to make sure that we are able to
uh to continue being active as a country
and as an economy okay james cleveland
education security could speak to you
thank you so much